[Music]
uh hello everyone this is grandmaster
alexander landerman
yeah with the new topic which i think is
very important for all of us
um how to convert winning positions and
make sure that
you know you don't let them slip by
because
as uh i think one famous gm said maybe
lasker
emmanuel asker the hardest thing to do
is to win a winning position
uh that's the hardest part of our chess
because very often you have many choices
that look like they're winning but
you know some of them make it a bit
harder and then it becomes
time consuming and it's hard to win
another reason why winning winning
position is hard is because very often
by the time you're winning you're in
time pressure
and finally just psychologically either
you start getting nervous when you're
winning
uh excited or
you relax too early and you start like
thinking i am winning easily or you stop
concentrating so those are all of the
reasons why
we can sometimes um
spoil winning positions um
and um
i'll show you several examples of when
the person was not able to convert a
winning position and we'll discuss
discover
um
i don't know
this guy
uh
oh
no it's it's it's not spam but he's
all right i mean he pay no attention to
him i got him okay um
yeah so basically what i was
what i was saying is that um
um
yeah i'm i'm gonna show you some
examples of where the guy spoiled
their advantage and we'll discuss why
that happened
all right so
let's start with this game
this is actually my game unfortunately
where i was black against um
legendary grandmaster
uh oleg rominicion he's older now but
he's still
obviously not bad
uh i was why i was black in this game i
was able to outplay him but
unfortunately he put up good resistance
and
i couldn't find the finishing touch
so
what should black do in this position
oh you're here to watch the lecture
yeah
yeah
oh wow so we got it we got a gm here
uh so you guys are
you guys are in luck
uh
tough competition today
um
all right so black to play how would you
try to convert this that's the
that's the question
uh
so joe bruno asks in russian who is it
asked who is dennis borish
uh not sure what i should say hungarian
gm
joe bruno is not paying attention if he
doesn't know who boros is
the legend
uh
uh okay so
okay push joshua hartman says push
through three on one
on the queen side
avinash is saying queen b1
hello ron nice to see you here
okay so so far no one really gave
a specific answer except for um
queen b1
which is a possibility
all right let's see
i'll give you guys like one more minute
ah thank you joe
um
oh
all right so so far we have queen b121
as suggestions
any any other
ideas
we also got knight d7
queen a6
all right all of these are our attempts
okay so let's let's see what i actually
did
um so what i did is i played queen e1
um
my opponent played bishop d2
king g3
and uh slowly but surely i lost my
advantage and
he consolidated
yeah this is already hard to win and i
eventually was not able to win the game
so queen d1 queenie one i think is a bit
inaccurate
now
uh joshua said correctly that we want to
try to push
our three-on-one advantage
so what is the most direct way we can
try to push our
our advantage um
knight g7 feels a little bit too slow
because we can go bishop d2 and try to
stomp her
on the pawns and same thing goes for
queen b1 we can try to go bishop d2 or
something like that queen queen
somewhere
um i mean all of these moves give an
advantage but there's only one
you know
way that you're brute force winning here
with black
and so the move you have to make sure
you calculate in such a position given
that these pawns should go is what
happens if you actually b4 play b4 now
maybe i considered maybe i didn't i
don't remember i might have just
rejected it after queen c6 i mean sorry
after queen c4 and it looks like
it's just nonsense because both this is
attack this is attacked it seems like it
just doesn't work however
when you as
sam shanklin grandmaster sam shankland
always says when you see an idea you
really like you have to look for a way
to see if you can do it anyway even if
you feel like something is stopping it
and uh and that's why
queen takes b2
you have to look further and queen takes
b2 is is winning for black because after
this
you have another very strong move queen
e2 attacking the bishop
and the thing is white will lose back
this bishop and once he loses this
bishop which is his best piece he will
end up with pretty much a dead bishop on
g2 and black will still be able to keep
one of his pawns and so a line like this
bishop d4 b2 takes takes
is completely lost for white because
he's stuck with a dead bishop black even
has mating attack ideas like knight g6
knight h4
but more importantly b3 queen c2b2
there's really no way to stop the pawn
and uh
and this is just lost for for white
so this would have been completely
winning right but it's important not to
stop a variation too soon just because
of first move right you have to look a
little bit deeper especially
if the move is logical from the general
standpoint of you right which is why my
general recommendation is in any
position before you start calculating
everything it's important to understand
what are you playing for in the position
and sometimes that will help you make
a certain decision that will help you
steer
your brain in the right direction in
terms of which lines you should
calculate which ones you should probably
not spend so much time on
okay so this i thought was very
instructive
um all right let's look at another one
this is actually
a game of ferugia feroza was playing
with the white pieces this game but it
was a rapid game i think it was against
lenia dominguez
in a online
rapid cup or something like that in the
beginning of the pandemic
uh ferruja as you guys know is a clear
leader now in the
uh grand swiss full point ahead with
three rounds to go has a very good
chance now of cour qualifying for the
for the candidates if his nerves don't
let him down
and in this game he very nicely
outplayed the
lanyard dominguez
um
i think he even might be number three in
the world after today's win but so queen
d6
now white played the very strong c5
putting pressure on the queen on d6
queen d5
queen e2 threatening bishop c4
so at some point black made a mistake
i think he had to play knight a5 here
and the idea was after bishop d3 there
is rook takes f3 but in the rapid game
this kind of tactic is is a bit
difficult to find
um so white always had a little bit of
an initiative and eventually black
misplayed it and uh
white got the initiative
and feroza is really really good with
the initiative um
i think i've even faced him um
in one game myself in a classical game
in 2019 when he was still a 2650 player
and i can already see that
it's world championship material he beat
me in
in a way that i would never have
imagined that he would be like a 16 year
old can win a game
like this from like a quiet position
that was something impressive
um
but yeah anyway that's
so here c4 d5 was very nice completely
shutting down black's pieces on the
queen side
c6 rook e5 queen g4
h3
queen g3 g6 total domination but black
keeps fighting
bishop a6 he wants to play knight b7
queen e4
and g6 and now
what should white
do in this position what would be the
best
way to convert
again before calculating try to
think about this position in general
conceptual terms that's always a good
idea before you start calculating
in okay first you should always look at
checks captures threats but unless you
see something that's like
directly winning then you should start
thinking conceptually
so why to play what will be the best
plan
i think this is quite a instructive one
as well
and i'm happy i said select the
difficult ones because i see a lot of
good players around here
ariana's also a very good player i've
seen him in some of my other classes
before so
um
all right row bruno says rookie eight
all right it's a possible move
see what else we have
all right bernardo diaz agrees
all right we have rookie seven
okay uh that's those are okay
okay
all right so it looks like we're in
between rookie eight rookies and rookie
seven does anyone have any other ideas
and rook h5
all right so joshua got the
the right idea yes
um
what we really want to do is is exchange
the rooks but we want to do it in the
in the best possible way
and um
so knight d2 or knight h2 would all both
both be
uh would both be very good and um the
idea here is after rook f1 f1 knight f1
would also attack the the queen
and then um
yeah black is in big trouble and
rook f2
takes takes rook e8
and if you can exchange both the rooks
then because of black's pieces being
completely away from the game
dynamically misplaced
then it makes sense that we try to trade
off all the rooks because then we'll
basically two pieces up in the attack
and should win which is why knight h2
makes sense trying to trade off both the
rooks
um
rookie 8 however
um
i think we can go knight b7
and
i'm not sure what the follow-up is maybe
it's also
not so bad but i think
knight d2 or knight h2 is simpler
in the game white played rook e7 and
then after knight b7
it turns out that
nothing clear and
and then
and then black was
black was fine all right so
um
all right this was a game of a chair
lagrav against greece shook from the
candidates 2020.
that was
the first half of the candidates
and
yeah mvl had very good prep in this game
and i think that
this is one of the reasons why he might
have not won the tournament
because had he won this game he would
have been
half point ahead and could have been
different everything could have been
different later on so
this was kind of a very
important miss for
grishouk and yeah so
this was a position critical moment
uh mvl played at this moment kind of
quickly and within three minutes even
though here probably should stink longer
because there are a lot of
possibilities here
so
what do you think
why it should
do here
uh
um
all right so looks like people are
starting to get it
um
okay let's look at uh
what mvl did first
he played bishop a3
black played c5
e6
f6
bishop takes knight takes
rook takes
fg
rook here king d6
rook here
and then came a5 a4 and
that turned out to be
enough counter blip for black to make a
draw
um so um
so bishop a3 was not
didn't work out as well because of c5
if we're to play six first then after
this
there's also
not much we can do
as a follow-up
and finally there's knight of seven
which
take here
here
rookie five and then it's also not
clear rookie 8 and this leads to
to a draw
and if bishop g5 then king e6 so nitrix
of 7 is also
um not winning
so the correct idea is we play rookie
four
which
attacks the bishop and it also takes
advantage of a loose knight and now
depending on what black does it kind of
disturbs black's harmony and depending
on what black does
we can decide what we will do so for
example if knight b6
we will go here
king e8
now there's no more c5 right once
knights on b6
and then we can play here and we have a
very big attack or even knight f7 takes
e6
um bishop e6 rookie six and
white is white is winning here pretty
easily
and of bishop h5 we have rook f4
so um so after bishop a3
we win here king e8 knight of seven
um and if black played bishop e6 we just
take and go bishop g5
and then look back
and then rook there so you see in some
cases the bishop ends up going to g5
some cases on a3 which is why it's also
good not to commit the bishop to a3
and uh and finally if they go bish b5
we have a very nice idea here i don't
think anyone mentioned it yet
what do you guys think white should do
in that case
i'm sorry
right very good rook takes c4 rook takes
f7 and then white has a very powerful
position
i think it's rook c7 actually and then
rook d8 we go bishop a3
yeah and white is basically crashing
through
okay very good so let's look at the next
one
so here it was a matter of calculation
seeing all your options and
just because you see a good move don't
play it immediately see a good move look
for a better move
um
now let's look at some
um let me see
more
uh
basic examples um
of that right because one of the other
reasons why we sometimes blow winning
positions is because we settle on
something simple
something that's good but we miss you
know something much better right we
missed the knockout
and uh let's look at some examples like
that
um
so
yeah in this game black really misplayed
the opening
and uh now the question is uh
what is the
most efficient way for white to convert
this
okay the queen is hanging so we have to
we have to be very careful
but you're right the it is an idea so
you have to yeah you have to think about
where you would want to move the queen
all right so everybody seems to want to
go queen d4 yes and this is actually
what
what white played it's a very tempting
move
but
as tempting as it is it's actually a
mistake because after we go queen d4 he
goes bishop e7
now we have nothing better to do than
just exchange queens right and yes we
will be better in the end game but it's
not a knockout there's still game to be
played and we cannot play queen e5 like
one person mentioned because of queen
takes d1 right so this is very promising
but it does not actually
win because now black is uh unpinning
himself and
position is unclear so actually
yeah we can play many moves here we can
play queen e2 queen c2 we can play
almost any move
uh with wins just not queen d4 because
here the problem is
we have two threats one thread is before
c5
and another thread is let's say black
plays queen somewhere i don't know c7 e7
what is the other idea white house here
yeah i think where the queen goes
doesn't matter so much as i mean c2e2e1
are they're all good but here yeah
knight g5 i don't think is so such a
great idea rook d stroke takes d6
queen takes d6
and bishop f4
and then
we're winning the piece for free right
so queen t4 is a very tempting move and
it's very easy to say okay it's good
enough you know clear advantage you know
clearly cannot be a bad move and let's
just play it
but again
when you see a good move it's very
important to be disabled enough to look
for a better move right not just settle
for
a cheap
cheap advantage um because this one is
not so easy to win and
white is actually not able to win the
game
uh it's actually from one of my students
games
all right so let's look at
another example
um
see
and this is actually from the great
magnus carlson
um
this is a mag a game from a while back
magnus carlsen against anish geary from
2017.
um
and okay the gay the first part of the
game i didn't really analyze
but very deeply but basically
carlson has outplayed gary in a nice way
wait what engine is this i'm confused
we're not using right now any engine
um
yeah so anyway we have this position
right here
and now
what should white do in this position
this is like a very basic example of
why it's important to follow this rule
you see a good move
look for a better move right this is a
very basic example but kind of proves
the point and even magnus carlsen fell
for this
kind of
thing um where he kind of played too
fast and didn't
didn't look for a better move that's
actually something that i felt for also
in the u.s championship and i've done
that video before where i played an
automatic recapture and it turned out
there was a better move so
so what do you guys think white should
do
uh
yes of course rook c8 is a
very simple win now now it's either mate
in three
or
you will lose the queen right either way
rook c8 black basically resigns right
the game is over
uh from this position i think any of you
can beat uh
magnus or geary it's it's an easy win
but the problem is magnus from far away
thought bishop f7 is winning and he
played the move very quickly because
the move also looks completely winning
but the only problem is it's not quite
such so easily winning because after
king h8
rook h5
king here bishop e6 how can he miss it
well simple explanation he saw a move it
didn't look for a better move right and
if even magnus carlsen can make that
mistake did not follow lasker's rule
then certainly
all of us sometimes could be vulnerable
for that right that's why it's very
important to remember
these kind of rules right
uh so king of six yeah and this was
already
this is still winning but actually only
with one move right and this is already
very very difficult
um
he had to find this move bishop c4
and after bishop c4 there is
95 rook h6 king f5
and he had to find some bishop d3 i mean
anyway it was it was complicated
so at this point you know nobody could
blame magnus for
you know not even magnus from his and he
spent a lot of time and he still
couldn't really
calculate it out right which is why i
didn't really want to
bother torturing you with this i mean
bishop c4 is just very hard right
but you know that's you know think about
it like now
it went from something very very basic
that the 1200 could see to something
that even for gm this would be very
difficult to calculate in 30 minutes
right so this is what sometimes you know
spoiling a simple win could mean like
right if you
just play too fast and don't don't
play the first move you see first good
move you see and don't look for the
battle move
anyway in the game white played like
this
bishop h3
and then you got this position which
ultimately magnus
couldn't win
and it's not winning
um
okay um
now i'll show you an example of
why it's important not to
ever relax too prematurely because in
this game i i have a student who
at that point it was around 20 over 2300
feet day
and uh and yeah that would probably be a
500 rated puzzle no i think i think
actually more like closer to 2000 but
anyway
um
but anyway
because i mean 500s are usually very
straightforward and simple usually the
ones higher are more tricky but that's
beyond the point
still obviously magnus should see it
yeah so in this game black played some
move
queen a5
and
white
and the question is
what should white do here simplest way
to convert this
okay this this is actually involves the
same rule right you see a good move look
for a better move right so even though
you know you can take on h2
you should still stop for a second and
think maybe there's something a little
better a little cleaner right and there
is there should be six there should be
six the guy resigns immediately right
there's just not
nothing black can do after bishop e6
maybe he can try knight c4 but still you
can take take take and then you're gonna
be the upper rook with queens off the
board right so then
it's a very easy win right and black
pretty much has to resign
but after king h2 it's up a piece but
there's still a little bit of
complications bishop c6 and the game is
not completely over right and now you
actually have to focus a little bit
so white played queen g4 which is also
not a great move
b4 was still
much simpler queen g4
and now cambridge f3 and suddenly
there's some clouds involving this king
right so it's very easy
to let your guard down in a winning
position even if you're a strong player
rookie one rook c4
and now
white should still play queen b6 and
white should still play queen d6 and win
but
unfortunately came queen b6
and now
came a very strong move knight takes g4
and suddenly
it's a big whoops because
after hg queen e5 check
and white is losing
all of a sudden
it's incredible
king h3 we have uh
bishop takes g4
and after king h1 we have rooked xg4 and
then we have check and checkmate so so
here white started to think for a long
time after realizing what
he's done
and um
kg1 also does not work queen e5
so amazingly only move is king g3
otherwise white is losing and the here
in black to black's credit black was a
much lower rate but here black was
really back in the fighting spirit
black found a very strong move to pretty
much
come all the way back in the game
so
what is the strongest move now for black
obviously the names of my students will
remain anonymous
now this one you have to be a little
creative but black found the move and
black was around a 2000 player maybe
2100 something like that
black found the move
so
so
so bishop takes g2 of course will not
work the queen is hanging right then
there's no mate queen e5 check does not
work because of king f3 and the king
escapes now queen h5 is very interesting
but then white can still do king takes
f3
even stepping into the
and then still not so easy
so
but you're close queen h5 is already
close
uh to the right idea
queen f5 yes
brilliant move and then
it turns out okay it's not like black
has a huge threat here but white cannot
do anything either
cannot take with the king and of this
now you go queen e5 and it's mate queen
e5 queen h2
and after hd you have queen takes and
queen g4 so after queen of fight the
game is completely out of control now
and clearand
white ended up going here 93
bishop f3 ended up giving back the
exchange and queen c2 and later on
um
white was still able to win the game but
after lots of sweat
you know even though you know if you go
all the way back to this position
it should have been so easy after bishop
b6 right so just never let the guard
down even if you think you already won
the game
remember you haven't won the game until
the game is actually over right and if
you see a good move even if it's a
recapture like that just a reminder
always consider a better move
all right so let's see um
let's see what this was um
all right this is actually another
interesting game from my student and
here my student is playing a g uh a gm
it's actually same student
um
and
and this is a very tricky line by the
way
that's
kind of good to be aware
of um
that a few people have shown me
actually jeffrey shawn recently in the
u.s championship played something very
very similar against me
and i thought he was going to go 96 and
i thought he was trying to trap me in
this line but then he's played bishop d7
which really surprised me
um because i thought the only point of
going to this line is to try to do this
trap and the trap is as follows
96
the most tempting plan for white in the
knight g2 systems is to play f3 and then
e4
right
um
but um
but black
has something in store against this plan
so f3 e4 is actually a mistake
white needs to play something else
rookie one for example king h1 f4
they're all moves but
this is actually a mistake because black
has a very nice
very nice tactic
so
uh if you know this then don't say it
but if you don't know it
um if you want to try to figure out what
should black
do here what is the trick here
after which black gets
a winning attack
right bishop d7 after 96 yes that's if
white does not play
f3 stuff yes
knight takes h3 does not really work
here
but it's it's an idea at some point of
course
but if you play take it here i think i
play gh and it's not so easy
um
so if we go bishop h3 i don't think that
does work for several reasons i can go
bishop g5 but i can also take
and then king g2 and i can even play e5
maybe as well so
yeah we need something more concrete
somehow that queen on d8 has to join the
attack
okay
all right so we have to play knight
takes it but you have to say specify
knight f takes e4 of course
f takes c4 knight takes h3
at one takes and queen h4
yeah and this is a winning attack and
here
in the game white played rook f2 what
would be the best idea in case of e5
this is the last point of this of this
trap
very nice one to know
yes very good rook takes e5 f takes e5
and t takes e5 bishop c5 and then
this is a winning mating attack
so
here at this point the gm realized he
fell into this very nasty prep he tried
rook f2
but still bishop h35 rookie 5 still came
takes here but white of course kept
fighting played knight e4
takes takes queen g5 knight g4
takes king of two so
the smoke sort of have clear yes eric
rosen yes he's the one he's actually the
one who showed it
to
to me at some point he's he's actually
the first person from who i found out
about this line yes so it's actually
it is eric rosen's idea so credit to him
um
so queen here rookie eight
king d2
yeah and here came comes a very
instructive moment because um black has
a completely winning position right he's
going to have five points for the piece
and white's king is open but
the game's not over yet white is still
fighting and gm's are very resilient
right so you know you still have to win
a winning position and
guess what black unfortunately lost the
game which is kind of a pity to
trap somebody a gm in a line like this
and then
to lose now this was an online games so
it's doesn't feel as bad it was it was a
it was a long online game though that
was during the heat of the pandemic when
people played like classical online
chess a lot so this was a game in 60
online so pretty serious game
so
the question is um
what should black
do in this position what do you think is
the best plan for black
yeah unfortunately black lost the game
yeah
um
so um
yeah so the correct idea is queen g5
here because what we really need to do
is we need to keep that king away from
hiding in the shelter so what we have to
understand is white's only chance is to
somehow hide with the king on b3a2 at
some point right running away with the
king and then the material disadvantage
it's still a lot five points for the
piece but you can still fight somehow
with the extra piece
um yeah maybe it's not completely lost
the real problem for why the reason you
know black is so much better here it's
like minus six
is because the king is very weak and if
you go queen g5 the problem is
if white goes king c3
black can go c5 and now the king is not
able to escape via b3
and the king is going to be completely
stuck right so now white's gonna
have to
lose a lot of material like this might
be the best line for white but this is
of course easily lost
um and if you go king e1 then the king
is just forever
boxed in over there then i go bishop g4
h5 h4 and it's
more or less just
winning for black
um
but unfortunately black played this
queen c5 queen g5 king c2 and the king
sort of got
to run away a little bit and even though
this is still winning
you know little by little it's becoming
a little bit harder
and uh i think d4 was also possible but
yeah this got a bit more difficult
and
you know white slowly
consolidated
now white got the chance to activate the
knight
and here black made the blunder queen e5
and allowed knight d5 very nice tactic
and suddenly it's not winning anymore
black had to go here
and after this knight b6 white even
managed to win the game right so it's
important very often with these winning
positions to put the knockout blow like
put the hammer down on them to really
make sure you don't let them out because
once you let them out a little bit and
they feel like they're back in the game
they start fighting like lions right so
that's very very important to to keep in
mind
um
and i think i talked about that in
in the end game lesson a little bit as
well
all right so let's see um
i don't remember if i mentioned the
wonder game and the insane and then game
i'll have to go back and look if i
didn't i'll probably i wonder yeah
yeah i'll probably need to
cover that game on tuesday then
um because that was kind of relevant for
a broken game but
okay but anyway um
just
see what else do i have here
yeah this one i showed
ah yeah this is a
this is a very good one i really need to
show this is a this was a very painful
game
um it seems like sometimes people they
see they have a winning position they
try to consolidate too quickly
um
i think you have to understand what kind
of winning position you have right
because
sometimes you have a material advantage
sometimes you have a dynamic advantage
you have like just a big attack right
and sometimes a little bit of both right
so you have to make your judgment and
understand how you should approach the
position right
um
you know and then based on that you have
to decide what should be your approach
in the position what you should
calculate
yeah so this game is again between
widget and navarra
and this was a very painful game
unfortunately for santosh vedic
who
out prepared
navarro played a really nice game in the
beginning but then made one slip up and
then even lost the game and as a result
he did not win a tournament where he was
leading with two rounds to go i was
last year 2020 prague masters the
tournament before
the pandemic basically shut the whole
world down
so
yeah so so far
so far white is
white is dominating
yeah so this a6 stuff is uh
is too slow so black
um
probably black should play
here um some other way but
like knight d5 or 94 but knight h5
knight c3
bishop e7 bishop c4 yeah here black
should play something like c6 but black
played this
and now white played
a very powerful move uh d5
um
ed bishop takes d5
knight g3 hg3
c6 and now
here comes the attack bishop takes f7
king takes f7
e6
king takes e6
queen e2 check
king f7
castle's long
bishop f6 yeah black is defending really
really tough
and here
uh white is winning and
has these winning attacking ideas
um
bishop c8 is um
is a try but this would be completely
hopeless for black
white has a winning attack here so black
tried queen e7
knight d6
yeah and here maybe white could have
tried queen c2 keeping the queen on but
it makes sense that white wanted to play
without too much risk
because the draw was also
still probably winning in the tournament
but yeah of course white still has a
very good attack maybe
yeah here black found a very nice move
knight d5 and uh the point there is that
after this check king f7 takes takes the
knight on b7 is is trapped
so black white black king b1 because
if knight c6 throws rook c8
so king b1
rook c8
rookie 1
bishop takes a3
knight takes c6
bishop b4 knight takes takes rook d7
yeah so white is still having a winning
position and black played a little bit
wrong at some point
here rook a8
um
and uh here comes rookie 7 rook h7
94
rook h6
rook takes
rook g8
all right critical moment right here i
mean there were definitely interesting
moments leading up to it it's a game
that certainly deserves a lot of
attention but since we're focusing on
converting winning positions
let's maybe start with with this
position so
how would you
play here and why
this is both calculation and also
general chess understanding
more general understanding though
you have to understand
what you're aiming for what black's
aiming for
we're up one but
still
not that easy
ah
so we have to pay attention to black's
counterplay there is a mate thread on d1
if we move the rooks so we have to be
very mindful of that
all right itai got it yes
so what do we have to understand in
the projector i'm this to fix it but
you're still there okay yeah what so
what we have to understand in this
position is that
uh white definitely wants to keep both
rooks on the board right because white
is attacking and uh
and so um
rook df7 is what we want to play and
after this we have just we just have to
see that there's a mate threat so
we play the move b3
threatening knight f6 and then black
really has no adequate defense here for
example knight d5
y plays knight g5 threatening rook g8
and white
has a
awaiting attack so the main thing to
understand conceptually is we definitely
want to keep rooks on the board
um
somehow and then we should be able to to
win the game but somehow white had a
brain slip i don't know what happened
but he played b3 immediately and allowed
the rook to get traded off it's like
a tragic brain slip he was he wanted to
play i think even the right move water
but um
unfortunately this thing happened to him
and um
and then he just could not really
readjust mentally like he blew the
advantage
and then he basically wanted to win at
all cost
at some point it was already not
winnable and black was repeating moves
but
a draw would have still been like
somewhat acceptable in his situation he
would have still been a clear leader
with
a round to go but he's still kind of in
his mind thought okay i must win the
game because i you know i was winning
and then um
and then he
managed to
just completely go crazy
over press and a lot and managed to even
lose the game in the most painful matter
and then he lost the last game and it
turns out if he would have even made a
one draw in the last two games he would
have won a clear first in the tournament
and then he ended up in a five-way tie
and then ferrucci ended up beating him
in a playoff it was so it's just
you know it was like
a tragic way how he ended up not winning
this tournament but
i guess sometimes chess could be
really cruel yeah white even even lost
this game sadly
not just the game but the tournament and
then just i mean
looks like he recovered but that was
tragic chess wise
um
let me see what this was um
i think this i'll save for an endgame
course
see
okay this is a little bit of a long
story i think i want to show
one of
a couple of enders with a couple of my
games
so let me
yeah i actually ended up playing two
games against uh and i am for
ryamandisha
and uh let's start with this one
and then i'll
show you the other one as well
um
so i at some point i
ended up um
finding this piece sack
to go 96
and uh
yeah if he takes i take on d4 so he has
to take
now if i go 96 first he takes
on um
here and then he takes on b1 and he gets
too much for the queens so i have to
take
now his only move is queen e5 otherwise
i go with g5 and i win
uh i mean maybe not the only move maybe
his objectively best is
not to play queen e5 but of course queen
e5 is the most practical move queen c4
queen g5 queen c6
and rook a7
and now i will not um
i will not overload you with trying to
calculate in this position but basically
white is winning in several different
ways
um
i believe um
yeah of course the first moves i looked
at was something like queen d7 check or
queen e8 and trying to get an attack
but um it wasn't that clear to me
because you can play c5 and he's somehow
kind of defending i thought it's not
that easy queen d7 i also thought he can
go
king of eight and king of seven
so it wasn't that easy
um
i think what i should have done is i
should have just um
made a list of all my candidate moves
from the very beginning and realized
that i had a pretty simple win that
would not require too much deep
calculation
which is bishop d4
simply attacking the rook and now the
only real defense is knight c5 and then
i go e5 simple two move idea
i went back tonight and this is very
clear cut like after this there's not
much black can really try it's just this
is just very easily lost
um instead i
saw that queen d7 queenie is on some
clear and then i got attracted to this
very interesting idea h4
attacking the queen
and here i calculated a very
long line
uh which looks like a beautiful line
and
it looked like a brilliancy but it had
one flaw
so the way it went was now he has to
take
rook h2 of course
and now black has
three possible moves yes that's right
three possible moves
the possible logical moves
so the question is how would you play
for a black here yes cameron exactly
um i think for your question cameron if
rook b7
it's not that easy because i mean the
queen might still get some
counter play and the pawn is still kind
of far away but okay it's
maybe i was also winning but i think um
bishop d4 is the most clear cut but
yeah h4
queen h4
all right yes it it's i got it right so
the easiest line to calculate was if he
tries to hold on to everything queen g5
and then of course it's an easy win i go
queen d7 then i go check and then the
key is i open up the rook and then i win
right so that was the first point
then i saw he can also go queen g3 and
here i also saw a very nice line queen
check queen check again
and now a very important bishop g7 check
force four and
and um luckily for me this is what he
played and i was able to execute this
nice combination
so if king f7 of course queen d7 so he
has to take
check check check check check and mate
so i saw this possibility too
and um
you know and my luckily my opponent had
a minute and he saw queen g3 he thought
he's surviving but it turns out he's not
i have this very nice mating sequence he
did not see bishop g7
and i thought okay for sure now h4 is a
brilliant like i thought okay amazing
game and very happy but then
later on as soon as i played rook h2
i realized to my horror that not only
does he have knight b8 but
the thing is i saw knight b8 from far
away and i thought that i could play
queen e8
from move earlier
but then i realized when when he was
thinking here that after knight b8
i cannot actually go queen e8 because of
a very nasty cold shower queen e1 check
and suddenly i lose because bishop takes
e1 knight takes e8
so i made a kind of a very common rookie
mistake when it comes to calculation i
calculated a very deep line after h4
takes queen g3 queen d7 like a 10 move
line or something like that
but the problem is i did not consider
very carefully on move two right the
possible options right and it's very
important before you go into deep lines
you have to see what's out there and get
in the position explore all your
candidate moves right and because i
didn't do that you know i was very prone
to making a miscalculation right so who
cares that i calculated this beautiful
line 10 moves deep if there's a two-move
repetition right
and unfortunately knight b8 if you would
have played it it's a draw because queen
eight i cannot play i lose
uh rook h4 this end game is not really
winning for me
it's also a draw
and
and if i go queen b5
i probably would have tried queen b5
now he goes queen g3
he controls d7 and now i could try queen
of one
like if queen b8 then queen f3 is uh
is very good for black like i'm up in
exchange but my king is horrible i'm
gonna lose this knight e4 f3 is coming
it's very bad it reminds me of my
game against fabi just now you know also
i was up on exchange but had the same
problem with my king
um
but i can go queen f1 but the problem is
it looks like i'm trapping the queen but
no
he has rook b7
very nice move
threatening um
well not threatening but basically
stopping rook h3 because he can beat it
with rook b1 now
a very nice tactic and then he's he's
doing well again
so it's crazy position and so now i
would have to make this very nice draw
by playing g5
queen takes g5 rook g2
and then after this this
he has to go queen g5 because if he goes
queen g3 he loses because of this this
queen a1
and if king f7 i made him on h8 and
after king g5 i go to win the queen
and if i don't play um
if i don't play g5 if i play bishop f f6
right away
then he wins with king g5
and even after try this
the king finds safe shelter on h3
so it's a a lot of very interesting
crazy lines could have happened but
they're not
you know when you're winning when you
have a winning position you don't want
crazy lines right you want to win in the
most clear-cut possible way right so
that's why in this position i should
have explored what are all my options i
should have noticed that i have bishop
d4 which wins fairly easily and then i
should you know if i want to i can look
for h4 to see if it's better if it's
more clear-cut
but if i'm gonna play h4 and not play
the simple bishop d4 line i have to be a
hundred percent sure that i'm not
missing something because h4 is a very
committal responsible move right if i'm
going to miss something after h4
you know it could be very very
bad right because i've exposed my king
right so we have to remember to be
practical with our calculations and
keep all of our things all of these
things in perspective
all right well i hope you guys enjoyed
this this lesson um you know the
the main lessons to take away are
improve your calculation and prove your
focus don't let your guard down you see
a good move look for a better move make
sure when you calculate you don't uh try
to go too deep into one line before
you've considered all the options on
move one or move two that's something
that mark varietsky always talks about
in his books
and you know just keep in mind all of
all these things and remember that just
because you have a winning position it's
not over until it's over
and uh hopefully you know you guys will
be much more efficient
in converting winning possessions i know
i certainly hope so for myself so
hopefully same for you guys as well
all right
do i have advice for improving
calculation um
yeah i would say that's what i talked
about today could be some of the tips
but other than that it's just training
the muscle it's just doing it all the
time and then if you have a coach then
the problems you get wrong go over with
your coach try to maybe he can find some
patterns you know why you're getting
certain problems right wrong so if you
get a problem wrong you have to try to
understand why you got it wrong and try
to find the pattern because once you
find the pattern
then you
can you know work on that pattern and be
more aware of it and improve on that
um
but it's hard like i'm working on that
myself it's not easy but
you know you have to start somewhere
right
do puzzle right no puzzle rush does not
help with calculation puzzle rush can
only help with with very quick tactics
it will help you with your blitz game
bullet game maybe but not actually with
your not so much with your long game
um
puzzle rush you don't it's not
calculation it's just
how quickly you could see a simple
tactic it's
a one move tactic it's or maybe a two
move tactic is it is it you're going are
you going to see it in one second or
you're going to see it in half a second
right that's a different kind of skill
we're talking about this is more about
calculation
rather than just solving simple tactics
yes exactly puzzle rushes pattern
recognition so which is important but um
it's a
and certainly you know i put it that way
i wouldn't
um i wouldn't be so excited if you can
get like uh 40 on puzzle rush all the
time but i would be concerned if you
cannot get to 20 let's say because if
you cannot get to 20 then i guess your
pattern recognition is not quite where
where you need it to be right
so i think um if it's if you're getting
very very low scores then maybe it's a
sign that you just need to
get more used to patterns so then in
that case you probably should be doing
tactics from a book
and uh try to you know unders learn the
patterns
um
you know but uh certainly if you're
scoring 30 or higher and you're pretty
decent then
then i would say that
you know your tactics are probably not
such a big problem it's more about
calculation or other things
uh aaron that would be nice i would love
to to do it i actually enjoy doing that
stuff so
um
blitz and rapid are useful well depends
on for what i think rapid training games
are definitely very useful
uh blitz um i mean i think it depends
with what purpose um
i think for opening training maybe for
if you have a time pressure problem
maybe but in general i'm not so sure
yeah the next one will be
next and last one with me will be on
tuesday
next tuesday
uh end game course
um so um so yeah that will be
that should be
uh yeah the next one
yeah on youtube i mean all right
all right see you guys
good night
[Music]
you